um hello everyone uh i'm hara
um uh so i'm gonna be at uc berkeley for
the year as a postdoc and then i'm
joining mit as an assistant professor at
the or stats group
and i'm going to talk about incentive
aware machine learning for decision
making apologies to those of you who
heard some sort of this
presentation during my job market last
year
so i'm sure most of you in this audience
know that machine learning algorithms
for decision making are almost
everywhere nowadays for example a
machine learning algorithm may decide
whether we qualify for a loan or not
whether we will get probation whether
after an interview with a video
interview software we will be invited
for an on-site interview and ultimately
be given the job of our dreams and also
whether students who are applying to
colleges
will be admitted to the colleges of
their choice
so because now these decisions are so
consequential for humans uh people often
times try to uh change to strategize
with the data that they feed into these
machine learning algorithms in an effort
to obtain better outcomes for themselves
so in the loan approvals example people
may try to increase the number of credit
cards or bank accounts that they have or
try various ways to improve their credit
history
in the college admissions example people
may try to improve their gpa
retake the gre pay for tutoring classes
and we've also seen this like very
interesting uh strategizing which is to
change schools in order to obtain a
better in-class ranking
and similar examples of strategizing
exist also in the video interview
software so for example people may try
to dress a certain way to hide piercings
or tattoos and change the way that they
talk
so what is the problem here the problem
is that if machine learning algorithms
ignore this type of strategic behavior
then we risk making policy decisions
that are incompatible with the original
policies goal
this is pretty much what
i'm studying in my research agenda under
the name of incentive aware machine
learning where uh we study the effects
of strategic behaviors
both to institutions and society as a
whole
and propose ways
to robustify machine learning algorithms
that are deployed for decision making
now every time that you hear the word
incentive aware machine learning
i'd like you to keep in mind that this
is a system that has three key
stakeholders the first stakeholder is
the institution these are usually the
mechanism or algorithm designers who
will create learning tasks for accurate
prediction in an effort to obtain some
goals like profit or justice in case of
the justice system
the second stakeholder is
individuals these are the data providers
uh and they can strategically change
their data however they deem fit in
order to get the best outcomes for
themselves
and then lastly the third stakeholder
is society as a whole
the actions that society can take are
very broad society can regulate we can
create public norms and expectations and
public pressure to institutions about
the types of algorithms that we want to
be deployed
and
the goals that society has again are
very broad we strive for fairness we
strive for robustness to bad actors uh
and an increase in the welfare of the
population
so this is a fairly broad categorization
of the three key stakeholders and i'd
like to give you a flavor of the types
of settings that i've worked on so far
so from the side of the institution
thinking about trying to
suppress the strategizing from the side
of the agents i've worked on algorithms
that are robust to strategizing and we
define robustness in two ways either
with the standard more economic way of
strategy proofness or a new way that has
to do with adapting with the incentives
of the agents
now whenever we talk about robustness to
uh incentives we assume that all of the
agents that are going to come to our
system behave exactly according to the
behavioral model that we have posited
for them
so moving away from these very strict
assumption uh i've started working on
algorithms that are robust to
irrationalities in these types of
settings which means that some of the
agents that we're going to face are not
going to behave according to the
underlying behavioral model that we have
now from the societal point of view
i have worked on the societal effects of
non-transparency for incentive aware
machine learning systems and i'll come
back to that closer to the open
questions that i'm going to tackle in
the future
so uh to give you an idea of the flavor
of results that uh my work has provided
i'm going to talk to you about the
strategic classification model uh which
uh we worked on with my advisor during
my phd yilin chen and yang liu
and this was uh disappeared in nurip's
2020.
so i'm going to be talking about a
repeated interaction between
an institution and individuals that
happens over capital t rounds
at the beginning of each round nature
chooses a feature vector xt this xt you
can think of it as like having the
original gre the original application
features of the agent
the learner picks a classification rule
alpha t this is linear in the d features
and the d plus one dimension corresponds
to the intercept that you can have
um now the agent observes the classifier
alpha t that the institution deploys
and their true data point x t y t but
they do not directly reveal x t y t they
instead decide to report something
potentially changed so this is the exact
t of alpha t
so how should you think of this x hat t
being generated
imagine that your data point uh was uh
like this thing here so this can
correspond for example to um having like
i don't know a gre of
this and uh like uh an in-class ranking
of this big
now the way that uh we uh allow the
agents to move in this setting is we
allow them to have a budget of delta
that they can move around
and if the classification that they are
assigned to from the algorithm is -1
they try to jump the classification and
fool us so this is the way that we
assume that the x hat t is produced and
we call these agents delta bounded
so what does the learner observe now the
learner observes this uh report from the
agent and incurs binary classification
loss which is essentially one every time
that the learner makes a mistake in
their classification
now the goal of the learner and remember
this is what we're trying to to do
mathematically we're optimizing for the
learner's goal
is to minimize this cycleburg regret
which is defined as the difference
between the cumulative loss of the
algorithm
minus the loss of the best fixed
classifier in hindsight had you given
the opportunity to the agents to best
respond
so just so that we're all on the same
page
differences from standard binary
classification in standard binary
classification the data generating
process
gives birth to data and then i receive
access to that data
i put a middleman in between so i'm
saying that data generates data
generating process produces the data
this data informs the person's decision
and according to the strategizing of the
person this is the data that i receive
so the take home message and uh i won't
have time to outline the techniques but
please feel free to find me afterwards
is that if you account for this delta
boundedness you can learn to classify
delta bounded myopically rational agents
in a nearly tight way which means that
we have both upper and lower bounds
and in fact the regret guarantee scales
adaptively to the power of the
adversaries this means that if the
adversaries are
very
very good against us then i will incur
linear regret but this is nearly nearly
tight
so
what i've done so far is i've told you
about this strategic classification
problem as if all strategies all
strategizing is bad
and so if we do believe that all
strategizing is bad one way to overcome
it uh
the complete extreme is to have obscure
machine learning algorithms
these algorithms stop strategic behavior
altogether but of course they are
non-transparent by definition
on the other extreme
especially when we talk about algorithms
for decision making if we have
transparent algorithms public algorithms
that people can probe and they can
understand them these algorithms can
potentially incentivize efforts for
outcome improvement but of course these
are prone to strategic behavior as we've
seen
i think that what lies in the middle is
interpretable machine learning
algorithms for new definitions of
interpretability that take incentives
into account
and i'd like to give you an idea very
briefly in one slide of where i see this
research going in the next couple of
years if this is the current state of
the research in incentive aware machine
learning right now i think that the
first set of questions that we all
collectively need to address has to do
with what happens if the learner designs
non-linear rules for example rules that
are uh that coming from weird neural
networks uh or that cannot be just
expressed exactly by a single uh linear
function
and then we can play around with
different models for agent behavior
agents can either understand the rules
fully or what i believe is
closer to reality they can understand
like approximations of these rules and
then try to best respond to the
approximations that they understand
now um the second step here
despite just building the perfect models
in the theory world is to really start
talking to policy makers and lawmakers
and people uh from uh the law and
different departments to build case
studies so that we can apply these
results in real life and i can give you
like a very brief example here which is
that
i was a trained computer scientist
computer scientist we love randomization
uh policy makers and lawmakers hate
randomization
so that that's like a concrete example
but why you need to think about these
cases and if you want to hear more about
that uh
me with ben edelman and joe chavez we
gave a tutorial at fact 21 where we
tried to translate uh this like
incentive aware machine learning
literature to lawmakers
and then finally i if we answer all
these things maybe we can hope to
achieve like interpretability that is
both robust to strategizing and
incentivize uh incentivizes honest
outcome improvement
uh in the interest of time i will not
tell you about the second theme moving
forward but it just has to do with the
way that we perceive agents behaving in
our settings uh and
i think that
incentive aware machine learning offers
an avenue for thinking beyond myopia and
best response in settings where we
deploy our algorithms for uh decision
making which i believe is the correct
way to think about uh agents as opposed
to thinking about them being completely
adversarial or satisfying some exact
utility function
uh this is a summary of what we talked
about today
please come find me afterwards if you
have any questions or comments and thank
you very much
thanks a lot for the lovely talk
questions
pretty nice thought and i wonder when
you mentioned that you have a nearly
tight bound for the regret so can you
establish any lower bound volume
yeah that's why it's nearly tight like
the in the paper we have both upper and
lower bounds it's uh the two bounce
diver by a logarithm
but
it's tight
nearly up to the logarithm
[Music]
as always very nice talk
i have a question about the the last
part of the
myopia and all that discussion so
in the first part if i got it correctly
we assume that the
the the mean the middleman
somehow is
able to choose perfect but to play the
best response to corrupt the the data
uh
do we have anything something like
limited power to the middleman
do we have any knowledge about what is
happening in that case he said that is
interesting
at all yeah
that's a very interesting question so
i i i talked about just uh the strategic
classification paradigm in this talk but
of course like incentive aware machine
learning encapsulates a lot of other
problems and that's what i was aspiring
to give you with this triangle view of
the world
so in other cases like for example
learning in stackelberg security games
that is part of this family of problems
there have been different assumptions on
the middlemen for example people have
assumed that people can only
approximately best respond
or they can best respond according to
some quantile
and very recently we've seen works
thinking about non-myopic agents meaning
that agents that take actions at this at
this round right now just looking at the
future ahead of them so not exactly best
responded
there have been studies for no regret
for agents behaving as no regret
learners in the context of auctions
maybe one more question um and the next
speaker can set up uh
[Music]
um i'm having a hard time thinking about
interpretable machine learning
algorithms that are also like incentive
aware uh can you give us just an example
of yeah
i guess contract theory
is everything is linear
and it incentivizes the outcomes that
you want
so can we have an analog of for contract
theory for machine learning
all right
i think that's
a faster way to describe but yeah it's
like the way that i imagine this area
moving forward is by defining the axioms
that we want interpretable algorithms to
satisfy so that they can simultaneously
incentivize
like some actions that we want and
suppress
gaming yeah
right
again what do you mean
yeah so in contract theory uh the
principle it's like standard principal
agent problems the principal announces a
contract right and according to the
effort that the agent will place
the agent will be uh rewarded paid
so
you basically are we good
do you need my laptop
okay
uh
so yeah but you are not but the contract
is kind of like static so like you
announce the contract once
then the agent participates in this
problem places the effort that they have
to place
when they once they're done it's over
so
this is interpretable because it's just
a linear rule
so i'm wondering whether something like
that can exist for machine learning or
non-linear machine learning rules
authority
thank you very much
thank you
okay for the final talk of the day we'll
be on adaptive online learning without
prior knowledge by chen new way and
we'll get started
you